un sens la meilleure
syndrome ma tête
je suis du restoroute de
fonctionner oui un peu un peu beaucoup
ou pas du tout ses fans un peu pour
c'est pas la bonne place la pourquoi
parce que vous êtes en face de chez nous
est ici lire une entrée pour les
voitures ici et là alors bon d'avoir des
relations de bon voisinage oui oui si
c'est pas le bon endroit
accor jambon fromage je n'aurais pas
compris et en rester là la maternelle à
la mozzarella
sallèles là d'accord
non
c'est bouclé et après vous pouvez pas
rester dans l'exacte sur le passage
piéton ici oui
comme stella 6 ans
je rigole plus je verbalise amende à
l'amande j'ai pas à mende
c'est un choix rien rigole bien fait pas
droit de vendre aux
allemands non il faut les vos papiers
les papiers du véhicule abidjanais votre
extrait k bis ou aux pistes au resto
sympa pas être malade mental ou est ce
qu'on fait là mais ça vous le mercure
paul saba
depuis ce temps par l'italien fiat en
mai qui fait la pizza la reine foutoir
pourquoi mais tu complètement mal à
tapas tête jean jaurès à l'aise face au
vol
alors l'épisode
une pizza à quoi non franco locaux apl
bits tu veux quoi à voir avec celle ci a
resserré la pop n'est pas très
connu en tunisie non il veut la petite
boutique sont enquis du code ou qui
scandaient le casse toi d'ici pourquoi
j'ai dit qu'elle soit 10 6% soit
abandonnés ici mais si je dois m'en mets
québécois tu veux pas tu as
comme infos là dessus et volent
n'importe quoi du mécontentement des
mois que vous croire est ce que ta vie
ta tête non mais t'as vu
là c'est moi je suis pour 2011 ça c'est
quoi s'énerve ça c'est de la merde il
importe au gatt et sa voiture au
home à petit ça
[Musique]